[Music]
we work with people throughout the
new england region and actually
throughout the country in an effort to
get
health information and health literacy
out to anyone who could benefit from it
coming into this specific school has
been a
definite new focus promoting
citizen science for the children in
order for them to
learn about health and wellness at the
early ages
was the first muslim stem school in the
area to get accredited
this grant for citizen science and
community engagement from the nlm's
new england chapter it's multifaceted
that's the first thing
to understand about it there were many
many different things that we were
tapping into
and yet they didn't stand alone this was
a all of us research program grant
and that was important because the
students are learning about all of these
things
around precision medicine which is the
future of healthcare
what is that yeah broccoli is that
healthy
we started out with our kids learning
about nutrition
learning about good dental hygiene
learning about a healthy lifestyle
and then that scaffolded into oh these
are the foods we should eat why don't we
grow our own food
and then connected it to our raised beds
outside
running the school garden and the
chicken coop was another example of
raising your own food when you speak
about health a big piece is
your body how do you take care of it
what are the different
systems within the body and that's where
nlm's resources came in really useful
i did a dissection on the heart and i
was most interested in learning about
how atherosclerosis occurs in the heart
and
using the medlineplus website provided
me with the information
that talked about how the heart disease
occurs
the symptoms and how to prevent them
[Music]
citizen science is also a lot about
collecting data about the world around
us
so we said well let's look at the world
around us wow we have the woods
in our backyard how about we open a
doorway
into the woods health and wellness is
everywhere we
having good resources with the nnlm
connection has made a big difference
it goes back to the national library of
medicine's
strategic goal of really building a data
driven workforce
and it's really important to start that
young to start kids thinking about
all of the different aspects that affect
their health that affect their
communities health
and really may impact their careers